[Music]
oh
princess minneapolis i'm bringing the
night pants nation tour your way april
28th through the third get your tickets
to those shows and all shows on my
website at
ryansicknews.com
come on princess
[Music]
the night pants nation tour continues to
add dates hollywood california june 4th
i'll be at the troubadour des moines
iowa june 24th one night only omaha
nebraska one night only june 25th june
30th i'll be back in praia california
also one night only special guest with
me that night will be jason ellis get
your tickets now at ryansickler.com
[Applause]
[Music]
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media
as always i want to thank you all for
your continued support of this show it
means the world the numbers continue to
climb and uh you're making a difference
over here in my life too y'all i really
appreciate it so subscribe to the
youtube channel especially if you're
watching and uh if you have to have more
do
um once you're done with the regular
honeydew there's the patreon it's called
the honeydew with y'all where i'm
highlighting the lowlights with y'all so
if you or someone you know has that
story that has to be heard please submit
it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com you do
not need to be a member to be a guest
it is only five bucks a month and if
you're in for the long haul you can sign
up for a year and get over a month free
and you're also getting the honeydew a
day early ad-free at no additional cost
all right come out and see me on tour
i'm continuing to add dates all tickets
for the night pants nation tour are
available on my website at
ryanstickler.com
all right that is the biz you guys know
what we do over here we're highlighting
the lowlights i always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers i'm very
excited to have this storyteller here on
the show today first time here on the
honeydew ladies and gentlemen please
welcome
jessica kirsten welcome to the honeydew
jessica thank you thank you for having
me well first of all thank you for being
here yeah my pleasure it was a pleasure
to meet you last night i am uh i am a
fan i'm a student of the game i know who
a lot of people are and they have no
idea that i know who they are they
certainly don't know who the [ __ ] i am
but i've been really stoked to get you
on um and i've been telling a lot of
people that you're an upcoming guest and
you got a lot of fans out there so yeah
i'm very excited i love your antics i'm
a big pratt fall [ __ ] fan
yours are the best yours are just like
you're just like a dead you just go you
just [ __ ] go i love it i love the
videos in the car
i love all of it so i've been watching
you and i'm stoked to have you sit there
in that seat today thank you i yeah i
met you at the comedy store last night
and the minute i met you gave me a huge
hug you were so warm i'm so excited to
meet you yeah thank you that made me
feel good you know it's sometimes it's
very awkward to meet people but you
really it was you were so
friendly and made me feel welcome it was
very sweet that's nice thank you for
saying that yeah making me blush over
here
um all right we've got a lot to talk
about but before we do please plug
promote everything anything social media
podcast shows all of it yeah well i i i
look promote my tick tock because i've
been posting crowd work videos every day
you killed one crowd thank you yeah
that's my big thing kill on crowlers
thank you that's very sweet i yeah so my
tick tock is jessica kirsten instagram
jessie kersten and my dates i'm on tour
so jessicacarson.com
uh and that's that's what's going on you
know i people should come see me on the
road
so they definitely should yeah
um all right so tell me about you i like
we said we met last night finally after
a long
wait and
where are you originally from
i grew up in south orange new jersey
uh and i
just grew up in suburbia great town all
kinds of people i love i love where i
grew up are you from a big family
not a big family um jewish not religious
liberal
you know not uh
just my parents got divorced when i was
uh separated when i was 12 divorced when
i was 13. not an easy age for that to
happen
uh they
both got remarried my mom married zach
braff's father from scrubs oh really
yeah
[Laughter]
so you got amazing your step brother
step step brother and sister
uh and then we ended up living together
in the house my mom is a therapist
um she saw clients in the basement of
our house my whole life which is did you
ever hear [ __ ] did you i heard
everything what's that what's the what's
the what's something that's burned in
there that you remember hearing a person
say to yourself
or your mom well i would sit on the she
saw clients in the basement so i would
sit on the stairs and listen to every
session we would and then i i got high i
mean i was i'm a drug addict so i would
i was a drug addict from day one
um well i started getting high when i
was 13. so
you would smoke weed we would all all
the siblings and all my friends we would
just get high and then sit on the stairs
and just eat snacks and listen to the
session and they're like i don't like
the way you're talking you know because
she she was a couples therapist so oh
we would listen no yes no you know just
screaming and um
and just crack up and just listen to
these sessions because she led groups
also
and my stepfather zack's father uh was a
lawyer big lawyer but he became a
therapist so it was like meet the
fockers because they ran courses
together it was hilarious in the house
they ran like a marital yeah
yeah so they did couples
courses on the weekends are they still
married well he passed
that's okay but they were
together what they were talking about
right okay so
so they yeah they took a ton of courses
together and they learned they took you
know became
counselors together like they got degree
like these you know degrees right and um
so they had like bonding weekends and
sex weekend it was crazy
so all these couples would come to the
house and do these weekends sex weekends
well like how to you know become more
intimate like people wouldn't be like
[ __ ] in the house right but it was
in the basement it was like anal weekend
everyone was doing
yeah we'd go in the basement everyone
have like broccoli in their [ __ ] no
and then my dad got remarried um and
they had two kids so i ended up having
a sister growing up but then i had
you know eventually four steps two
halves and a full sister and you know
i'm very lucky because everyone got
along and my parents made it great
and you know my parents
sorry i don't mean to interrupt you
everyone got along your mom and dad
still got along after this they made it
okay and we all went to family events
together and sometimes would celebrate
holidays together and
you know everyone
made it work
and my step siblings would go to events
with my half siblings and you know it's
like
really i'm lucky because it was never
like i'm not going to this because this
one's there and i i really yeah
it would i'm really blessed that that's
how it was for me i'm curious if
there's anything that you heard on those
stairs that's etched in your brain
forever
no nothing didn't hear anything has
etched in my brain forever but
you know at the time
there were no cell phones there were no
beepers there was nothing right so i
mean i'm a 70s kid so my mom didn't she
was disorganized with when the clients
were coming very so she would forget
they were coming i mean
this was extreme
so a lot of times clients would show up
and she would be gone for the day so i
grew up in jersey she would go to the
city for the day new york city so
sometimes two three clients would show
up and i didn't know where she was so
i'd have to like
let them in
and they would just be waiting for her
and i'd have to like say to them i don't
know when she's coming back yes
it's like a sitcom right it's amazing
yeah so they i would just but also as an
adult don't you think you'd be like i'll
come back right
but they were used to her being late or
maybe not showing and meanwhile these
people have abandonment issues it's so
crazy that's why they're staying that's
why they're stuck so i'm like i don't
know and it was i was enraged
i was in rage because i would be like i
don't know where she and i'm a kid so i
was like her secretary
so sometimes there'd be one person there
or two like this waiting room in the den
you know just waiting for her
um
and you know it was weird to have like
this business out of the house yeah and
i had a quiet business right and i had
to be quiet my whole life
because she had these clients so i was
always being silenced it's part of why i
love being a comic because i can be loud
i have a microphone i could say whatever
i want because i was always being told
to be quiet and don't walk around too
much don't make noise and
you know it was hard being in a home as
a child having to always be quiet
yeah amazing well you you mentioned
addiction
early you said you were smoking weed
early what's what was the first thing
you had alcohol yeah the first thing i
tried was alcohol what age oh god well i
mean i think my dad gave me a taste of
alcohol when i was very young maybe
eight or nine but i
i tr you know started drinking at 12
started smoking pot at 13 but
immediately was like oh this is how you
don't feel your feelings and you just
get numb and
you lie
yeah of course um
and
from
you know the get-go was never like i'll
just do a little i mean i'm an addict so
i immediately
was a garbage can and just wanted to use
a lot
um and
that was when i started you know just i
was always the one you know out of the
group that that wanted more and more and
more and more
when did your parents find out
uh well they didn't know i was an addict
until like my 20s when i was like i'm
going to rehab okay so you never had you
never got snagged with a dui or any of
that [ __ ] that they found out about no i
mean i got caught with alcohol in my car
when i was in my you know in high school
but that wasn't like i just you know the
cops i was in the car with my friends
and i had open alcohol in the car but no
i hid i hid my drug use very well you
did yes i was great at lying and hiding
were you the only one did you know if
your other siblings were using as well
or you just keeping to yourself and
shutting the [ __ ] up about it yeah no i
was um i mean you know there's there's
i'm really the there's other addictions
in my family like there's food food
addiction is very big in my family
yeah yeah um
but i think more so
i'm the only you know in my immediate
family not in like the branches of other
things but in my immediate family i'm
probably i'm the only one with like a
drug and alcohol problem
yeah what was your drug of choice
um
i mean marijuana has always been the
go-to it's always the one that you still
smoke no i don't do anything i'm
completely a hundred percent sober
i keep hearing about california so well
that's what a lot about that yeah i
don't know what's that
is that what that is yeah i don't judge
anyone for anything and everyone does
their own thing
but for me
um
being sober is a hundred percent off
everything because
it's
being sober for me is no mind altering
drugs and pot is a mind altering drug
and
anytime i have smoke pot
eventually i have gone back to alcohol
and drugs there's never been a time and
trust me i've tried just try yeah i've
tried
many times to smoke pot and even if it's
a year or three years later i will
eventually take pills or
have a drink
or you know because really being sober
is being sober off of everything
including pots so when people say
they're sober
um that means off of everything um
so i uh you know being in california is
very tricky because uh you know
a lot of people say they're sober but
they smoke pot yeah and in new york you
know
it's or where i live you know being
sober
for the most part is no one smokes pot
well a lot of people here tell you sober
they're [ __ ] doing cocaine every
night too yeah there's a lot of [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah um what happened to
make you say hey i need to check myself
into rehab what was it well i have gone
out i've been sober you know i was sober
eight years and then started um using
again i've been sober six years and
started using it i mean now i've been
sober a while but uh
what happened every time is that
well the first time
okay the first time
the first time was um
i
knew that i was powerless over drugs and
alcohol that i could not stop on my own
i hit an emotional physical and
spiritual bottom
where i uh
was at my wit's end i was not okay i
felt horrible physically
um i could not stop using drugs no
matter what i tried like i couldn't stop
like i could not
um wake up and not use
you know it was the first thing i
thought of it came before everything
um it made my life unmanageable in every
way shape or form like it can't it it
came before family friends were
everything it didn't matter like that
was my first thought the second i opened
my eyes
um
and
i wanted to die i was just miserable
miserable person uh
and
so i actually sent myself to rehab
i mean that's that's powerful right yeah
a lot of people say they've had an
intervention they're caught by surprise
or whatever but for you to be self-aware
that's good for you yeah i that's kind
of what always made me believe in a
higher power also i'm not like a
religious person but you know i've been
saved so many times by i don't mean save
like i've been saved but like yeah but i
know that i there's something out there
that has looked after me because i've
driven drunk so many times i've been
just there's something protecting me
because i should not be here right now
uh
you know something just made me just
call up a rehab and say
you know i want to come there because i
i
i knew i just knew that i couldn't
i couldn't use i just
it's had control over me and um i can't
have a little
i just can't but you know addicts were
so sick i'm so sick that if i don't
work a program if i don't you know work
on it really hard every day and it's an
easy simple thing to do it's not that
difficult the things i need to do to
stay sober it's very simple
um
i will my brain is so crazy that i will
start thinking eventually i can just
smoke a little pot like believe it or
not i will start thinking that i can i
can have a drink alcohol is not really
my thing
or i can you know what's what's a big
deal i can take a xanax i'm really
anxious today like that's what happens
to your brain let me ask you so let's
say you start smoking weed you say
eventually you always shift to something
else do you now get rid of the weed is
it is the weed a progression to alcohol
or you said pills or whatever like are
you then or is it all oh it's all in
okay yeah
yeah for me it is yeah so how hard is it
for you to work in this business i mean
there's weed and alcohol and pills and
coke and everything running ramping
through these buildings
when i'm working on my program so when
i'm connecting with people who are also
sober and i have like a network of
people when i'm
um do going to meetings when i'm you
know praying when i'm meditating when
i'm
work
most of all before anything helping
other people
when i'm doing service which means i'm
helping another alcoholic
or addict when i'm
um volunteering was because
addicts are very selfish people we're
we're very self-involved and and focused
on ourselves and
me me me me me me you know it's oh i'm
always like in my head and
you know self-centered uh not in a mean
way but just
like
just always talking to myself and
thinking about myself so when i get out
of myself and focus on someone else and
try to help someone else
i'm i'm always in good shape you know i
i don't even think about
using drugs or
i mean i'm in really good shape so i
barely think i i really don't even ever
think of
using drugs or alcohol how long have you
been clean and sober now i've been back
a year and a half oh good for you
because uh i wasn't working a program
um this is what happens when i stop
working a program i eventually will end
up using and during covid
this is what got bad this for so many
people i slowly stopped doing the work i
was doing
cove it happened and then my father
unfortunately passed away a month into
kovid oh man yeah from cancer and it was
bad it was really he got sick very quick
um thank you pancreatic cancer and he
and i was if i had been working a
program and doing all the things i just
mentioned to you i guarantee you i would
not have relapsed but i started smoking
pot
and
uh
and didn't go full force into other
things but i
when i do that
like i said i have to start over i have
to be honest with myself and i had to
start counting days
and it killed me
but i have how long have you been
up to a long time years years wow so i
but and some people don't do that they
just say oh i just smoke pot i'm just
gonna but i for me i had to say
it was hard but how many days did you
how long was this binge
not too long it wasn't too yeah it was
like it wasn't that long it was a couple
of minutes yourself again did you rehab
or did you just no yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay but but you know i did go away and
deal with some trauma stuff because i
was very traumatized by his uh
his death it was
it was hard and all the coveted stuff
and a lot of others it was really really
hard to deal with all of that um were
you there were you yeah i was but thank
god he was home okay
thank god he wasn't here
i know i all those people that dealt
with that i can't even imagine and are
still dealing with stuff with that it's
so hard did you get to say goodbye
i did i did he was he was
it was hard with him
he was very angry when he passed um
he
was
not
in the he wasn't in the frame of mind of
i want you to be happy
um i want you to have a great luck you
know he was like
he was angry when he passed he had an
angry face
you know i i pictured his he had this
angry face like not ready to go he was
very ready to go he was right yeah he
was very ready what do you think the
anger was he was angry he was an angry
person yeah i loved my my father was the
funniest person i've ever met in my life
which is a huge thing for us to say
we're comedians i've met every
famous i mean for me to say that is it
he was brilliantly funny like he made me
laugh harder than anyone in my life
um
he was
you know he he had anger and
he was in a lot of pain and very
uncomfortable and he just wanted to go
and he's like can you believe i'm
[ __ ] alive still a [ __ ] one you
would say
can you believe i'm [ __ ] alive
yeah it's like a brooklyn macho like
jessie [ __ ] died
[Laughter]
he's like what the [ __ ] you know he's
enraged
i love it i know
but he didn't you know i wanted him to
just be like i love you and i want you
to be happy and it wasn't that
and he looked i couldn't get his face
out of my head this angry just this
angry face and you know i you know i i
was like i love him he's like i love you
love you how many times you're gonna say
i love you like it was a lot it was a
lot for me to deal with
and um
i didn't want to show up and i did you
know thank god i just i was angry at him
like i i was like
i i wanted this
time with him to be like loving and it
wasn't
and
i
he was nicer
you know to my my other two sisters and
i i know he was he couldn't deal with
some stuff with me i i know he couldn't
he couldn't get vulnerable with me i
really felt that i know how much he
loved i know how much he loved me
and i think he couldn't deal with it
with me in certain ways like we had this
strong bond and i i'm telling you i
think he couldn't he couldn't go there
with me yeah in certain ways
um
but i did some work around it i did some
trauma work around it and i did this
thing called art which is accelerated
resolution therapy it's i'm not that one
believable yeah so people do emdr that's
what i'm in now you are
okay i love that you're doing the mdr
i'm just my second time doing it okay i
went originally for
anxiety so very quickly my daughter
almost got hit by a car and it unearthed
anxiety that had just been laying in a
hammock with his legs crossed down there
just waiting to show up and then all of
a sudden i'm scared to fly i had never
been scared to fly oh yeah and i'm
scared of heights and i'm like i i was
talking to dr drew about it i'm like
it's all new he's like i know exactly
what you're going through he sent me
this lady
and she worked with me for a few months
and boom i can sleep on planes now i can
fly i knew i had to get over because we
got to do it for our job like i can't be
[ __ ] scared every weekend
so it worked and now i'm going back for
you know new stuff because i'm not
you're never fixed you're never from so
glad you're doing it
i love it so art is the same thing
except you go for one session or two
sessions to to to fix it's exact same
thing it's eye movement therapy
but you only need one or two is that
right it's like that kind of power i
mean we
yeah
is that real yeah i don't need to sit
there it's buzzer's in my hands it's
real good
so i went to the back power yeah
tell me yeah
so i went for a bunch of different
things and
the biggest thing i went for was with my
dad i couldn't get his face out of my
head i couldn't image that angry angry
face and and and the experience of him
dying
um and saying those things to me like
you know all that stuff that that whole
experience of him dying and the anger
and all that [ __ ]
and i went and i got rid of it i can't i
can't
when i'm right now trying to picture
the way he looked i can't i just tried
and it went away
so i literally just tried to picture it
and my mind swiped it away so you go to
this therapy with um like individual
things so i'm here for this we work on
that next i'm here for this we're not
throwing a whole pi junk pile together
no i did i have gone and thrown a whole
junk pile and it'll get you through all
of it yeah now it's worked most of the
time there's a couple of times it didn't
work but i worked on a lot of stuff to i
went for a whole thing about my dad
to forgive him for a lot of stuff and it
worked um
and i you know
the work i did about him was i ended up
kind of seeing him as a child um
and
uh
i was able to do it because he had a he
had a very very very difficult mother
and i was able to forgive him for a lot
because he didn't come from great right
situation
uh
yeah
is it an hour-long session or is it more
intense hour and a half
and you're doing constant eye movement
the whole time
and you've done the emdr and do you
prefer art is it a art i say i did a
long like a long thing of emdr for like
months or weeks yeah but i
i have had
very good success with art but it has to
be someone who's really good okay i've
gone to uh i've gone to one per one
person with art who was not good
and i've gone to two who are incredible
the one that i went to was one of them
originated it in west hartford
connecticut oh wow okay and she was the
originator so she's amazing and the
other one i went to at the center i went
to in florida was incredible also
look into that yeah i'll give you the
information i want all the mental i say
all the time like we're also trying to
work out our abs and our muscles and
[ __ ] and nobody's up there working their
minds art is unreal all right it's i'm
excited amazing i've gone i've
i have been cured of things in an hour
and a half
i'm not kidding it's sound i don't
people can say
that's ridiculous you can say whatever
you want you though lie to me i forgave
my father in an hour and a half so
people
now listen i'm the child of a therapist
i've been in therapy since i'm eight
years old so people can say whatever i'm
52. they can say whatever the [ __ ] they
i don't care what they say i've been to
every kind of therapist there is i've
been i forgave my father
of a lot in an hour and a half so i've
wasted
thousands and thousands of dollars on
therapy over a lot that i cured
in an hour and a half so i don't i mean
i don't care what anyone says yeah it's
insane like i left there and i'm like
if i had done this
at 20 i would have
saved
tens of thousands of dollars crazy hours
of therapy and crazy i went when dr drew
said oh it's not talk therapy i was like
hang on a second i know
i didn't say anything you all call it
talk therapy in your world like i just
thought it was therapy you know what i
mean and he's like that's talk therapy
this is the mdr this is this this is
this i'm like holy [ __ ]
yeah and that emdr was something else so
i feel like this sounds like the next
level up and i'm i'm i'm definitely
going to go try that out yeah
and this woman this
woman um
she deals
a lot
mostly with veterans yep um yeah she
does a lot with firemen and cops and
yeah people like that people who have
witnessed you know murders god the [ __ ]
they must i know it's unreal
yeah and they their minds they just wipe
it out it's gone
have you ever just been too damn high
with today's weed it can be a dangerous
game and i know you don't always have
time to play reefer roulette when you're
looking to light up i get it alright so
if that's you then dag grass is reviving
the pleasure of the casual smoke so you
can chill out without the stress that
grass is legal organic smokable hemp
that relaxes your body and mellows your
mind their 100 percent organic pre-roll
joints are very low in thc and high in
cbd so you can enjoy the effects of cbd
while you're keeping a clear head and if
you want the toke without the smoke
that grass also has a cbd tincture made
with the same high quality hemp it's
easy to dose and the effects come on
smooth it's like having a glass of wine
not the whole bottle and hey if you're
looking to get off of cigarettes and you
like the habit of smoking give this a
try all dagg grass products are
federally legal for ages 18 and over and
it ships right to your door anywhere in
the u.s whether you're looking for a new
buzz or a chill way to enjoy an old
favor daggrass will leave you in a
euphoric mood right now dag grass is
offering my listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to dadgrass.com
honeydew go to dadgrass.com
honeydew for 20 off your first order
that's
dadgrass.com honeydew for most of us
learning a second language in high
school or college wasn't exactly a high
point in our academic careers all right
i took spanish and like i started in
eighth grade and i think it was 11th
grade when i was hitting the ds and it
was lowering that gpa you know what i'm
saying but now thanks to babel the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you'll be traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
family or you just have some free time
babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you'll actually use in the
real world and babel's 15-minute lessons
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go other language
learning apps use ai for their lesson
plans but babel lessons were created by
over 100 language experts their teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective with babel you can choose
from 14 different language including
spanish which is what i'm taking right
now french italian and german plus babel
speech recognition technology helps you
to improve your pronunciation and your
accent there are so many ways to learn
with babel in addition to lessons you
can access podcasts games videos stories
and even live classes plus it comes with
a 20-day money-back guarantee so start
your new language learning journey today
with babel right now you can save up to
60 off your subscription when you go to
babel.com honeydew that's babel.com
honeydew for up to 60 off your
subscription babel language for life now
let's get back to the do
so i ask everybody to send their um
bullet points in their little trauma on
a list and and there's a few things on
here i want to talk about um you you put
on here you're coming out process
so talk to me about that like what age
do you
come out and how do you do it and who do
you come out to first
it's not even like i think um the trauma
of that
i came out when i was in my 20s
and i think the most traumatic thing
about that uh and i came out um
after college uh it was the trauma of it
was the secret of it
and
me caring so much what people thought
you know my family was amazing about it
from such a great family where they
really were more concerned about how i
would be treated in the world and that
i'd have to you know hide it and
people would judge me and that i could
never be free they never thought i'd
have kids
um they never thought i could get
married legally you know stuff like that
but they all accepted me and loved me um
the trauma was more the hiding the lying
i was in a secret relationship for three
years because i had met my first love in
college and i was a senior and she was a
freshman
and we hid it so it was meeting in
hotels and lying and dating guys so that
people would think we were straight i
mean it really almost killed me it was
horrible wow um
living a double life it was horrible
yeah so that kind of
hiding and lying and i know i know
people who relate to this that are
listening it's like if you're in a
having an affair or if you're in love
with two people or whatever i so many
people can relate to this it can kill
you it literally can make you feel like
you're gonna die
um
and also caring so much what people
think
and feeling like i'm a sinner and i even
not even though i'm not from a religious
family just feeling like there's
something wrong with me um
and i st believe it or not i still have
that a little bit because of what
religious people have said even though
i'm not religious
i still have that a little because of
this
extreme right [ __ ] yeah
um
so
that that was traumatic for me
um it was what age do you
understand that you're gay
so i always uh was a tomboy
um
and i i had crushes on boys when i was
younger i i'm not i've never felt a
hundred percent a lesbian so i'm
definitely like i'm
i guess i'm bi and very much
prefer women so i i would i had was
sexual with some guys but i never could
fall in love with a guy
sure
who did you lose your virginity to first
guy or girl i was with girls like i
would fool around with girls when i was
a young girl like which is very common
um i
was with girls before i was with boys
um i had lost my virginity to a boy
when i was
17 in a not a good way because i did it
at my freshman orientation for
university of maryland
in a room from we're also up your turn
yeah yeah all right yeah yeah
you did this at the orientation i did
and it was and i was wasted and the only
time you lost your virginity and that
the only reason why i did it was to say
that i
did it before i went to college like it
was horrible because i was getting rid
of it right and i was out of my mind
wasted and there was another random guy
and a girl in the hotel room in the next
bed i mean it was really crazy like it
was like you lost your virginity in a
threesome in a no well they were they
were in the next bed having sex and it
was like i just did it to like say i
could i had sex before i went to college
like i wasn't i didn't even know the guy
and i just did it like because all my
friends had had sex and i was about to
go to college it was like the summer
before
i went to college
um and
i
went to college
and uh i just you know i would date guys
but never be into them
you know always like if i slept over i'd
be like when can i get out of here just
never wanted to spend time with them
and all my i had so many straight male
friends but
i never was in love with them or had
feelings like that for them
um i could enjoy sex but i'd have to get
wasted
and i would be like attracted to girls
but i didn't never knew what it meant or
what it was
and then i met this girl in college and
i just wanted to be with her 24 hours a
day but i didn't know i was get i didn't
know what that meant like it wasn't like
it is now you know you didn't back then
in 89 90
no one was like gay like it just
when i we were that age like in college
it wasn't
no one was like out
where i was like in my
surroundings
um
but you know i fell in love with this
girl like i fell in love with her wasn't
even like a sexual thing i literally
fell in love and
still didn't think i was gay for years
and i was with her i was just like it's
her it's just her it's not because she's
a woman
and uh
and i had shame about it for years was
she out already no we both were our
first yeah oh you were her first as well
okay
and
you had shame about it for years years
after or while you're dating you mean
while we were together and
just
didn't understand what was going on am i
a lesbian like while we were together
and then i would just like kind of be
with guys
you know when she was still in [ __ ]
because she was a freshman i was a
senior while she was still there and i
left him like you know sleep with some
guys and be like you know am i
only attracted to girls what's going on
i was so confused
uh yeah
were you um
what's my question
you
okay were did you ever introduce each
other to family as friends or anything
like were people aware of her
well they we they all knew we were
friends okay but
er so she wasn't you guys weren't hidden
completely from each other's lives no we
were friends we were like best friends
but when we when i told my family my
mom's like well obviously well i was
hysterically crying because i was so
freaked out about telling people
and my mom's like well i knew like my
mom's a therapist she's like obviously i
knew you were together uh
you would like cry when she leave like
i was like melissa yeah
just going home
my dad cried when i told her because he
thought it was his fault because he was
very verbally abusive at times so he
thinks he
he he was very self injured oh my god
it's very nice
fault that you're gay
i know isn't that so narcissistic
i did this i know i know
and my
and he feels
like i know i know
i'm [ __ ] amazing
really their concern was more how i'd be
treated in the in the world because
again this was 93 or so i gotta imagine
they're also with this couple's therapy
they're probably hearing some couples
with kids who are gay who are getting
abused sure you could have walked down
the street
holding hands at that you couldn't do
anything at that point
and then my sister literally the way i
told her and she would oh she'll say
this to this day thought i had cancer or
something like she literally thought i
was dying by the way i told her
i mean i was like she thought i was
dying
so she was like
and she was not surprised no one was
surprised when i told them
um
you know it was more my stuff it's
always been more my stuff about it
no one i mean i had a friend who when i
told her this is horrible but when i
told her she told she didn't want me in
her wedding party anymore i know isn't
that horrible yeah for real yeah isn't
that horrible that is it's petty and i
still went to the wedding it was
horrible you did go i did and i ended up
fooling around with a guy there i got
really wasted and fooled around with the
guy at the wedding and i it was
disgusting like i fooled around with him
like in a hallway at the saint regis
which is one of the fanciest hotels in
new york city
yeah
yeah
that was horrible
that she did that
but um
yeah i've never really gotten anything
about it i've been treated pretty well
and i'm grateful at what point do you
become comfortable i know we could we'll
say never in your own skin though what
point do you embrace
this is who i am and this is how we're
moving forward what age would you say
and
you see you came out at what 22 you said
no i was about like
24.
um i
i think it took years for me to really
be comfortable
uh i
i don't know i'm it took a long time it
really did
i started um
you know i i
i talked about it on stage uh
you know after a long time i did gay
shows for a while i started talking
about it more
on the road and stuff
in in clubs uh when my career started
taking off more and i could
i also started talking about it
very openly
when i had children because i was like i
will never hide this so that they feel
ashamed right that's when i really was
like i am not going to be ashamed of
this because i never want my kids to
feel yeah you got to break definitely
yeah i never want them to feel like it's
not okay okay so tell me um
24 you come out takes a few years to get
comfortable at what age are you a mom
first how old are you
so
zoe
um how many kids do you have again i
have four daughters four daughters yeah
i have a women's march
[Laughter]
you got a mini women's march over there
you do
um
so i
the my first daughter
was
born when i was 36 yeah
yep
so
zoey is gonna be 16.
yup she's i can't believe that
yeah so driving with her yet
actually my ex just sent me a video
yesterday of her driving with her i
can't even believe i drew over there
once yeah it's crazy crazy
she's an actress she has an agent it's
insane she's an amazing actress
yeah
yeah she's in the school i know it's
insane she's she is
uh she's the she's in the school for the
performing arts half the day she's
amazing incredible performer
um
and
uh she's unreal and uh and then i had so
i've won with my ex and i have three
with my current wife you have two you
said you had two baby mamas i do i'm a
rapper
my rapper name is lil jew
lil jew pill popper
okay tell me what that's like tell me
what it's like so you have one with your
ex
okay when did you meet her
i met
my ex this is great i was flyering for a
comedy show isn't this amazing
for stage time
yeah i was downtown in new york city
flyering and she took a flyer
she thought i was a flyer for a living
isn't that great she thought that's what
i did for a living i was like 20
i was 29.
and then she came to the show
and saw me perform and that was it we
got together we ended up we we had a
wedding we eventually after dating for a
while we had a wedding but it wasn't
legal at the time right
and this was nine what 2000
and uh and then we decided to it's crazy
to say that [ __ ] number
and still think that
gay marriage wasn't legal 2 000.
i mean that is ridiculous yeah
a lot of people wish it still isn't
legal
or want to reverse it trust me
a lot
this world is ending anyway so
so uh
yes so we had a wedding and then we
decided to um
have a kid so we you know did in vitro
she carried um
we had zoey
and then we ended up
you know not it didn't work out and then
we
broke up and then i eventually met
danielle who's my current wife
we wanted to have a child and so we did
and we had isabella who's now i love
that name isn't it great she's called
her bella and izzy and so cute and bella
is
six and a half now okay and then we were
like oh well maybe we'll have you know
another one have bella have a little you
know little sister and then
we
um did in vitro again and we had twins
oh there's my god it was insane are they
fraternal they're fraternal and they're
all girls
crazy so i four so they're three
so i have
i have a 15 and a half year old six and
a half year old and three-year-old twins
man you are [ __ ] how do you have time
for anything in life well i'm listen
this is the question i want to ask you
because i'm setting you up sort of and i
didn't mean to but did you take the
lesson from your parents of co-parenting
successfully across the board with
everybody
yes now this is the deal my my
oldest does not
they don't all spend time together
so my my
you know my ex does not
like zoey doesn't spend time with the
other three that's the way that it has
ended up
um because if my ex doesn't want that to
happen so it's it's a little upsetting
frustrating but that's the way it is
um
my
butt everyone gets along but you know
what they're all going to grow up and
they're all going to want to talk to
each other they are because no matter
what we try and do around each other i
know and then social media is that's the
good i know i know i hate social media
but it's not like we were in the 70s 80s
where you ran into somebody at the store
like oh my god the general store yeah
forever you know and they have all been
around each other and isabella's been to
zoe's shows and it's not like it's a
horrible tense situation
um and yes i mean i get along with my ex
very well and you know everything's fine
thank god everyone gets along i see zoe
all the time and
um
yeah and they're both great moms i'm so
lucky my kids are amazing and
uh they're unbelievable i'm really
blessed and i'm not you know like you
i'm on the road constantly so i have
these incredible women who are like
great mothers and
danielle
is a therapist also like my mom can you
believe that my wife's also a therapist
is unbelievable who does zoom sessions
from home i mean this is all sitcoms
it's full circle so
yeah
i know
sometimes i can hear them but it's
insane um
but so she
you know works part-time
and she
brings up the three i mean she's
incredible and she's always like go do
what you need to do go work it's i'm
very lucky
because i mean you know you have to be
with someone who's like okay with us
being away like she's always like do
what you need to do go on the road do
because i could never know
i don't bring the money home to pay for
my hands my [ __ ] yeah i gotta work go
[ __ ] work yeah
yeah good
yeah
and you know we deal with a lot i mean
we have on you know i was talking to you
about this but our six and a half year
old has has heart disease she has a
major congenital heart disease
um unfortunately we
isabella um
we found out when she was danielle was
six months pregnant that she has what's
called truncus arteriosus it's very rare
um
it's crazy it has that name her her main
heart valve
her it looks the bottom looks like a
trunk so it's all mangled it's a
nightmare
um
and so
we had found out that
the minute she was born she would need
open-heart surgery
right minute i mean right out of the
body into surgery yep good lord so we
had to make plan that you know we had to
find the best doctor and thank god we're
in new york city uh we
we went to literally
one of the top
doctor heart surgeons in the world
it was an it was a nightmare
a nightmare i i can't imagine
so um
so you got to hand your newborn baby
over to these doctors to do a heart
surgeon right into tiny little pick you
yeah unreal so
she was born
uh six days later she
you know
chest opened
open-heart surgery
um
they didn't they weren't even able to
fix the main problem which is to her
heart valve they weren't the main heart
valve they weren't able to fix that
they were able to um
put in another tube she has two big
problems but the main one they weren't
able to fix
um to make a very long story short she's
had three open heart surgeries i know by
six and a half she's had three
open-heart surgeries and a stent she's
had a stent put through her groin
already
and
she needs a lot more
and um
you know a lot of people want you to say
i've noticed which makes a lot of sense
and i get it that everything's okay
you know when you have a child with a
health problem well she'll be okay right
she's okay right everything's fine right
she doesn't need more surgeries right
and i'm like no
she will be okay but she's not done
and she needs a lot more surgeries and
she needs more
a candidate for open-heart
transplant she doesn't need a transplant
hopefully she needs um
she needs uh
she doesn't need a new heart she needs a
heart valve she needs a they're waiting
as long as they can
for the main
valve replacement
um is that because as we grow and uh
that's the other thing i'm wondering
about age and their whole thing so
cause more damage
yeah so she has an appointment monday so
she what they do is we take her every
six months she has to get the whole
thing the the the ekg the this the that
and so
we just pray every six months that she
gets the okay because she has a leak
it's crazy
it's a lot it's you know it's
uncomfortable for people to hear but
it's like we just want the thumbs up
every six months she's okay for the next
six months she's on medication twice a
day for the rest of her life
um
and it's just
you know we prolong it as long as we can
because your heart grows and like at a
certain point it stops growing what do
you know what age what age they say
around like your teen you know 13 14 15
you know that that it's that
they just want to keep prolonging it as
soon but but the pro you know the other
thing is is that tube
because it narrows this other issue she
has and that's why she's had to have the
other open-heart surgeries to replace
that
could fix yeah
and then so that they've had to do so to
speak what is that good to go now
it is for now but that's why she's had
to have the three open hearts and the
stent because that will narrow or has to
be replaced so that they might have to
you know
go in and do the other thing they might
be able to do that right so they don't
have to do this to crack exactly
daughter's chest open two more times
jesus i know
now how's her scar do they always go the
same place
it's extreme
she has a
huge scar and then she has
50 other
neck
i mean they're all white but you know
yeah it's a lot it's it's a lot
her whole back it's a lot i just met a
girl a friend named daisy who has scars
from stuff like that all over her body i
don't know what it was froms i don't
want to ask but she hated them and i'll
be honest you said white that's exactly
what they were they were white and i i
listen i know it was trauma that she
went through but it kind of looked
awesome to be honest with you it was
almost like an alternative to tattoos i
know what you're going through for that
[ __ ] but it it i thought it looked tough
i really do i actually get what you're
saying you know because to me it's
they're very light um it doesn't look
bad like it doesn't they're not they
look like little bird feet that's
exactly what they look like right yeah
and
it's not
uh to her to just a part of her like
we're more traumatized by it than she is
um
[Music]
but she definitely has stuff
about it like there's
you know loud sounds or beeping because
she's was brought up in hospitals so
that
like any kind of sounds she gets
i mean she's not like nuts with that but
she definitely has stuff
it's a lot it really is a lot but
looking at her you would never know
that she has open hearts you know that i
mean she has heart disease you would she
looks like a normal
beautiful six-year-old kid i mean as a
mom as her mom do you try to do you hold
it together when she's going in or do
you just [ __ ] lose it you always do
you can't you don't even you as your
parent you know like i i you would
you're able to do it yeah when she when
there is nothing worse tell me the
moment
rolling her down i have to tell you
you know we have to get dressed head to
toe in these outfits the two of us are
covered with the whole thing the the
whole costume your shoes everything you
know
and then this sounds horrible but you
know you've talked about this i'm sure
all these kind of things on this podcast
but you have to roll your kid down a
baby
into an operating room i've done it
[ __ ] 10 times because she's had so
many procedures besides these open
hearts and all this stuff i've had to
take her down for a lot of different
things
besides all those other things and
you know
we have to hold a thing on her face
to put her out
with the doctor
so we go down with her
into the operating room
and we're standing over her while she's
going under with this thing on her face
and she's screaming through it
mommy and you
oh
yeah it's
yeah so i'm holding her legs and her
feet and danielle's over it's
there's nothing i know have you gone to
the atr atr right for that art yeah a rt
art right
yeah
and has it worked has it helped it has
it's there's nothing i would never not
be able to hear that even if my kid was
a mom with two kids um
yeah there's nothing where i mean it's
it's helped me in my life
put perspective on everything you know
people you get upset about something in
this dumb business about not getting
something or
why did i'm like uh yeah there's nothing
worse than that
i mean i do you know i've spent months
in hospitals like when we when she goes
in for something
we had we've had to spend a month there
like in the beginning like you'd
literally move in right we move into a
hotel right a couple blocks away
um where we spend three weeks to a month
there and i've had to sit and watch
people hear that their kid died
like they take the parent away when it's
just havoc there and there's 700 things
going on
so like when i
hear
when i see like i'm in a comedy show and
there's been times when i've been so
burnt out on the road
and i see like someone looks so
miserable at a comedy show you know when
you're burnt out and you're doing
[ __ ] sick shows in a weekend or
the how enraged i feel when i see
someone like look enraged in an audience
or
you know um i've seen you call people
out
yeah some of your videos it's hard for
me sometimes
or just when i'm around someone who
keeps complaining about dumb [ __ ]
you know in personal life or something
i'm like why don't you go to in my head
i'm like why don't you go to a
children's hospital and sit in the lobby
and then keep complaining about this
stupid [ __ ] thing you keep
complaining about yeah you know i went
and gave blood um my friend steve simone
he's a great comedian he's yeah i know
steve you know steve he had set a whole
thing up here at l.a children so we
would go down and
and give blood as a matter of fact
giving blood to those kids ended up
saving my life it was [ __ ] crazy i
donated blood
um and then very shortly after that i
got um kidney stones and then i had to
get all this blood work done to find out
that i have this blood disease that's
from my father who had died already
and i'm prone to clotting and i it's
called factor five and wow all the [ __ ]
that i never would have even known
that's incredible all that so and i was
sitting in there watching
you know these parents lose their
children and and steve and i were able
to um i'm really proud of this actually
we he he called me up and he said do you
know anyone that knows
a way to get to steph curry and i said
yeah i actually i know
um a guy
who is damon bruce is his name he was
the he is the bay area sports guy does
the sports already i've gone to promote
some stand-up shows when i was in san
francisco on his network so i hit him up
like hey i know you do the vo or the
voice for the warriors but is there any
chance you could just even get this
message about this mom and it was her
boy was gonna die and he was
a huge steph curry fan she's like
we would take a pair of socks like this
boy before he goes would love it so
damon's like i can't promise anything
but what i can promise is i can get this
to the person that needs to get this and
i was like that's the best thing we can
answer not only did they get it to him
the game was in la he came to la he
dedicated the game to the boy
he met his family before and him gave
him tons of [ __ ]
goes out at that point in the season he
scored over 50 points in the game they
sat him in the fourth quarter because he
was killing it had his best game that
far and then after the game met with the
family again gave him game warm stuff
worn stuff and everything and then
and then the boy passed shortly after
that and his mom wrote this [ __ ]
letter that i just was
i mean just about how [ __ ] unfair it
is and exactly what you're saying people
want to say this and this but i'll tell
you it's not
yeah it's not okay things today are not
okay and this is why i'm feeling and man
i was just
losing people want you to say
you know it's okay and and they answer
their own questions like you know she'll
be okay and you know or they'll be like
yeah my my cousin had a hole in his
heart and he's fine i'm like no it's not
a hole and i i know you're saying that
to make yourself feel better but this is
not just a simple hole in the heart this
is not just this this is a major problem
and it's you know she'll be okay but
it's major this is not
yeah so you've got
at least seven eight more years of
whatever is going to happen now before
her heart is grown and then and mine
might she might have issues when she's
20 she might have i don't know like we
don't know that this is a
we don't know but we know that she's in
the best possible handshake we're very
lucky because we're in new york city at
columbia presbyterian and that
the columbia presbyterian has a um a
cardiac children's unit which is unheard
of like that's it's it's the best place
she can be
with the best doctor i remember seeing a
photo years ago in time magazine of open
heart surgery on a baby it was literally
it's insane it looked like doll parts
it's crazy isn't it yeah it's it's
insane these big human hands are in
there doing all this stuff to that
little tiny heart it's unbelievable
well i'll never forget it was a nine
hour operation and he came out of the
operating i mean out of the elevator and
he had two thumbs up and we were like
what did that feel it was i i it's
unbelievable
it's unbelievable
she's a little soldier i know
it's really it's hard to not get into
like why me why us what but it's like
why not
yeah that i'm telling you ryan the stuff
i've seen at children's hospitals
when you look around
when i've
things i've seen i'm like i am so
grateful like i have seen the worst
situations
that i'm lucky
i'm lucky like i don't remember
it's bad yeah
stuff is bad like the some of these
parents the stuff they have to deal with
like this is not the worst situation
stuff that parents are stuck with the
rest of their life it's bad i [ __ ] up
the saying all the time but it's
something like uh they say if if
everyone stood around and threw their
problems in the middle of a circle you'd
you would take years back right yeah
that i've heard i know what you're
talking about you know what i'm talking
about like yeah i'm just going to keep
my yeah yeah i'll be i'm okay with my
stuff yeah
all right well listen first of all thank
you for coming on and being so open and
honest i know this is not easy to talk
about it's your baby
um well it'll help people not feel alone
so that's good so thank you for doing
that yeah we got to get you out of here
because you got another place to get to
but before you do
advice you would give to your 16 year
old self after what we've talked about
today what what would you say
um i would probably say
uh fight your fears
um
stop eating so many carbs
i love me some bread
you're so cute
um
no uh you know just don't care so much
what other people think
and keep the focus on
you
and uh
always be silly
get out of your head like that get out
of your head
don't talk to yourself so much because
it's uh it's most of the time it's going
to be negative be present
um
and uh
you only live once just
live life fully
yeah
that's great be free yup
thank you so much thank you um plug and
promote everything again please yeah
jessicakerson.com for upcoming dates
tick tock jessica kirsten instagram
jessiekerson and uh i have a podcast
disgusting hawk forgot to say that in
the beginning but you can find it on
youtube at
uh
jessicakersoncomedy and uh that's really
it thank you so much you're great thank
you thank you for coming on here go see
jessica on tour
uh and as always ryan sickler on all
social media ryan sickler.com we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]